foreign
[Music]
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
brothers and sisters and dear friends I
saw this video which I was absolutely
shocked and I'm just talking to the
Western People the ones who are liberals
who are following this way of life Satan
is real and they are coming for your
kids this is a movie of Santa Claus or
whatever maybe lack of Muslims we keep
our kids away from us because we don't
believe in Christmas and all that kind
of stuff however look for yourself what
they were portraying in that and look at
this so even call it a subliminal
message let's watch for ourselves
singing by e spelling
I mean guys you can't make this up do
you guys really believe normal some
parents who may have maybe watch this
video do you believe this was a
coincidence do you not think they did
this on purpose Allah says to us in the
Quran Iblis Satan is an enemy take him
as an enemy they are brainwashing your
children showing them blatant texts of
Satan under the Skies of Santa oh it was
a mistake for elsid yeah right yeah
right we should brothers and sisters
protect our kids when Allah says
something albeit or you will end up
regretting it and learn it the hard way
and for us that we take and protect our
kids from a young age looking at them
from a young age not just as being a
role model yes teaching them Quran
teaching them that teach them the Salah
the connection with their lord this is
their survival mechanism it's the Quran
and the Sunnah Islam is there as a
survive for a guide for survival in this
jungle and in this jungle they want your
kids they want your kids because once
you infiltrate the kids the new
generation is corrupt protect us and may
also cannot allow us to spend more time
educating our kids rather than following
the Dunya and at the cost of losing the
Dunya losing ourselves and losing our
kids to the satanic world that we live
in
assalamu alaikum